new evidence that America's coronavirus
pandemic is at another dangerous stage
and the trends are pointing in the wrong
direction this is not good the number of
new coveted patients hospitalized for a
day has jumped more than 35 percent in
just one week Los Angeles County which
has more people than any other county is
reinstating an indoor Mass mandate even
for people who've already been
vaccinated because of what health
officials call substantial Community
transmission and last night's Red Sox
Yankees game was called off when six
Yankees most of them vaccinated tested
positive for covid one of them just got
back from the All-Star Game raising new
worries about the spread of the virus at
this week's sold-out event in Denver
Lilia Luciano is in Los Angeles Lilia
what what's the potential risk out there
now
good Morning Anthony here in L.A County
about 60 of the eligible population is
fully vaccinated but that means that
millions of people are still unprotected
Health officials say the Delta variant
is taking advantage of that
vulnerability
for angelinos a reminder that progress
against coronavirus is fragile LA county
has recorded more than a thousand new
cases per day for the last seven days we
will be implementing an order requiring
masking indoors regardless of
vaccination but that decision may have
unintended consequences says UCSF
infectious disease Dr Monica Gandhi the
mixed messaging of saying that you have
to mask when you're vaccinated will tell
the unvaccinated oh actually the
vaccines don't work over the last month
the daily rate of vaccinations fell 60
vaccine hesitancy remains an issue in
the U.S something Surgeon General Vivek
Murthy blamed uncovered misinformation
which he declared a national health risk
on Thursday it's painful for me to know
that nearly every death we are seeing
now from covid-19 could have been
prevented
I say that as someone who has lost 10
family members to covid-19 and who
wishes each and every day that they had
had the opportunity to get vaccinated a
Kaiser Family Foundation survey of
unvaccinated adults found that
two-thirds believed in at least one of
several vaccine myths the white house
pointed to an aggressive online
misinformation effort by a handful of
Bad actors there's about 12 people who
are producing 65 percent of anti-vaccine
misinformation on social media platforms
that stat comes from a report by the
center for countering digital hate which
is calling on social media companies to
shut down those accounts and others like
them entirely Imran Ahmed is the group's
CEO look social media has sort of
transformed the way that all kinds of
misinformation is spread and you can
test out thousands of different messages
seeing what works what doesn't the
problem is that we we're playing
catch-up and in many respects the
tactics that they're using are more
sophisticated they're more devious then
we've been able to keep up with
social media companies say they are
working to combat misinformation both
Twitter and Facebook told CBS news they
do take the problem seriously and are
taking aggressive action against
misleading covet content Adriana lelia
thank you so much